so somewhere around 1941 to 1942 the
Axis powers recalibrated and they said
my gosh we're now in a war with the
United States since December 11th 1941
we are a war with Soviet Union since
June 21st of 1941 and we never conquered
Great Britain and we have not been able
to bomb the enemy into submission or
even in some cases even reach the enemy
so then what happened
well what happened would be then that
there were two races so to speak
concurrent races in Japan and Italy and
Germany they recalibrated their
strategic and industrial policy can we
make a fighter that is so much better
than anything that the Allies have can
we have a new weapon can we have a new
bomber that can somehow rectify our
tragic mistake of taking on economic
industrial and military powers beyond
our comprehension in 1941 there was a
active discussion both in Germany and in
Japan that something had gone wrong
these border wars that had been so
successful in China Southeast Asia
Europe had now blossomed into something
they hadn't quite conceived of and the
answer as we're going to see is going to
be no they did not build a four-engine
bomber they did not build fighters that
were capable of ensuring air supremacy
and they did not train pilots or
maintenance crews that could ensure air
supremacy meanwhile in the United States
and Great Britain and the Soviet Union
there were quantum leaps in technology
and industrial production and remember
one other thing is that the United
States was 3,000 miles distant from
Europe Great Britain was always an
island so even though through
isolationism and appeasement the
democracies were not really ready for
World War two there were people within
them that understood
would there ever be another war you
would have to have a means of hitting a
European city that was hostile with
bombs from your own home bases whether
it was the United States or whether it
would be in Britain and that created a
need for a four-engine bomber so as
early as 1936 and since 37 the United
States had developed this wonderful b-17
bomber and Britain had experimented with
a Handley page or the Stirling short
bombers again for engine bombers were
billed as early as 1937 to 39 in the
democracies and the axis had no
counterpart to that and that gave them a
head start because from the b-17 you
would get the b-24 and then later the
b-29 and from the Stirling short or the
Handley page you would go to the
Manchester than the Lancaster so by 1944
and 45 when we talk about strategic
bombing were essentially talking about
an allied phenomenon the Axis powers did
not have the equipment the technology
the training or the expertise and they
simply ceased even trying to do it